I'm the charmer out of the group and
you're giving me lower ratings
I'm the Chava to go wet where the
hostess hey we're the hosts of all right
and this is cha battle hey we're the
hosts of queer art and this is charm
battle Bobby yes I hope you know CPR
because honestly you take my breath away
get that 1 to 10 whoa call an ambulance
because your beauty is killing me
you kinda remind me my pinky toe it's
cute and I'd probably bang you out of
the coffee table
I'll give it a 10 I can't see any stars
because you outshine them all hey was
your mama beaver because damn don't you
ever do
are you tired you have been running
through my mind all day
that was fucking hot that's ten whoa
you're hotter than the bottom of my
laptop that feels like a five yeah give
him a low feels like a five fewer booger
I'd pick you first to point that there
are 21 letters in the alphabet
no you're right I forgot you are a cutie
that was a breeze you must be a broom
because you my dear young man just swept
me off my feet
chim chiminey chim chim since you've got
back we're older than you might think
are you a camera every time I look at
you all I want to do is smile six that
was generous I'm assuming you're a
magician because every time I look into
your eyes everyone else disappears that
was good
ten thanks I think we're all winners
I'm the winner
now we're gonna play our second game
it's where you try to stick a card in
Tani's Oh